This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. All right, coma. About 10 miles south of San Francisco, out toward the airport. There's a town called coma. I have never been to coma before, but it's cool you can take the train right here. That's producer Avery Trouffleman. Oh, all right, oh my God. Right beyond the train station, already these big rolling green hills
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。好的，科尔马。在旧金山以南约10英里处，靠近机场的地方，有一个叫科尔马的小镇。我以前从未去过科尔马，但你可以坐火车直接到达那里，这很酷。那是制片人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。哦，好的，天哪。就在火车站后面，已经可以看到这些巨大的起伏绿丘了。
peppered with tombstones. 73% of the land in Colma is covered with graveyards. Oh, and they're just rows and rows of big gravestones that look like little houses. There are 17 full-size cemeteries together in one town, 18 if you include the pet cemetery. This is huge! It is a city of the dead, what's known as a necropolis.
上面点缀着墓碑。科尔马73%的土地被墓地覆盖。哦，那里到处都是一排排巨大的墓碑，看起来像小房子一样。在一个小镇里聚集了17个全尺寸的墓地，如果算上宠物墓地就是18个。这太庞大了！这是一座死者之城，也就是所谓的“死者之都”。
We claim to be the only necropolis in the United States anyway, the only city that is primarily dedicated to cemeteries. This is Moreno Conner, president of the Colma Historical Association. It doesn't mean that there are a lot of cities that don't have cemeteries within their boundaries, but nothing of the concentration that we have here. And Colma truly looks like a sprawling city, a landscape of mausoleums and monuments and towers and tombstones that glint in the sun for as far as the eye can see. But it is eerily quiet. Here the dead outnumber the living a thousand to one.
我们自称是美国唯一的死者之都，也是唯一主要致力于墓地的城市。这是科尔马历史协会主席莫琳·康纳。这并不是说有很多城市在其边界内没有墓地，但没有像我们这里这样集中的。科尔马看起来确实像一座庞大的城市，一片陵墓、纪念碑、塔楼和墓碑的景观，在阳光下闪闪发光，一眼望不到边。但这里出奇地安静。在这里，死者与生者的比例是一千比一。
We have 1600 living citizens, and we have about one and a half million residents who live underground, or in mausoleums. Maureen talks about her dead neighbors and her living neighbors with the same vocabulary, like when she referred to John Daly, the long deceased Dary magnate. John Daly, for whom Daly City is named, one of our neighbors. She's a lot of famous neighbors, like Joe DiMaggio, and Levi Strauss of Levi Jeans, and Tina Turner's dog is in the pet cemetery. They're all around, and Maureen's house is literally
我们有1600名活着的公民，还有大约150万名住在地下或陵墓里的居民。莫琳谈论她死去的邻居和活着的邻居时用的是同样的词汇，就像她提到约翰·戴利（John Daly）时那样，他是早已去世的乳制品大亨。约翰·戴利，戴利市就是以他的名字命名的，他是我们的邻居之一。她有很多著名的邻居，比如乔·迪马乔（Joe DiMaggio）、李维斯牛仔裤的创始人李维·斯特劳斯（Levi Strauss），蒂娜·特纳（Tina Turner）的狗也安葬在宠物墓地里。他们无处不在，而莫琳的房子简直就是
sandwiched between two different cemeteries. I live across from the Italian cemetery in the front of my house and then the back of my backyard borders with the Japanese cemetery. And then I have two human neighbors on East and West. The official town motto of Koma is it's great to be alive in Koma.
夹在两个不同的墓地之间。我住在意大利墓地的对面，房子的前面是它，后院则与日本墓地接壤。然后我在东西两侧还有两个人类邻居。科尔马的官方城镇座右铭是“在科尔马活着真好”。
It's great to be alive in coma. It's great to be alive in coma. Coma had many lives before it became the modern necropolis. Before it was even called coma. In the 1800s, it was rich farmland since it caught all the moisture off the bay. And most of the vegetables for San Francisco were grown there. At another point, it was known mostly for hog farming, and at another point, it was known mostly for hog farming, and at another point, it was known for cultivating flowers. Meanwhile, a few miles north in San Francisco proper, people were pouring in because of the gold rush.
在科尔马活着真好。在科尔马活着真好。科尔马在成为现代死者之都之前，曾经历过许多生活。甚至在它被称为科尔马之前，19世纪时，这里是肥沃的农田，因为它吸收了海湾的所有水分。旧金山的大部分蔬菜都是在那里种植的。在另一个时期，它主要以养猪业闻名，而在另一个时期，它以种植花卉而闻名。与此同时，在北边几英里的旧金山市区，人们因为淘金热而涌入。
The population was booming, and so was the death rate. Well, certainly there was an enormous amount of death at that time, and just because there were no antibiotics, people died of stuff that you wouldn't even think of dying of now. San Francisco's cemeteries started to fill up and starting in 1887 religious groups and organizations began, one by one, to buy plots of land south of the city to create new burial grounds, which eventually covered over two square miles. In 1924, the cemeteries got together
人口激增，死亡率也随之上升。嗯，当时确实有大量的死亡，仅仅是因为没有抗生素，人们死于现在你甚至想不到会致死的疾病。旧金山的墓地开始爆满，从1887年开始，宗教团体和组织开始一个接一个地在城市南部购买土地，建立新的墓地，最终覆盖了超过两平方英里的土地。1924年，这些墓地联合起来
and they decided to incorporate. Those 2.2 square miles officially became a town, a cemetery town called Laundale, which in 1941 would be renamed Colma. And all of this was happening in the context of a much bigger change in American burial practices. For a long time, the dead used to be buried in little squares or church yards on dusty plots in the middle of town. Graves were all around, it was no big deal. Municipal barren grounds were right downtown and they were relatively small,
决定合并。那2.2平方英里的土地正式成为了一个城镇，一个名为劳恩代尔（Laundale）的墓地城镇，1941年更名为科尔马。所有这一切都发生在美国丧葬习俗发生巨大变化的背景下。长期以来，死者通常被埋在城镇中心尘土飞扬的小广场或教堂墓地里。坟墓随处可见，这没什么大不了的。市政墓地就在市中心，而且相对较小，
crowded places, with really nothing much by way of landscape design, they were just, you know, the land surrounding a church. This is Keith Egener, professor of architectural history at the University of Oregon. And in his book Cemetery's, he talks about how these tiny plain graveyards were hubs of activity. You might find a plumber or a brick layer or a carpenter, you know, seated at a cemetery waiting for someone to come along
拥挤不堪，几乎没有什么景观设计，它们只是教堂周围的土地。这是俄勒冈大学建筑史教授基思·埃格纳（Keith Egener）。在他的书《墓地》中，他谈到了这些微小而简陋的墓地曾经是如何成为活动中心的。你可能会发现水管工、泥瓦匠或木匠坐在墓地里，等着有人来
and employ them. Farmers would graze their cows and cemeteries because many people believe that the grass grown in church yards or burial grounds was richer and made for sweeter milk, prostitutes, even, would sometimes be found in burial grounds. So these were open public spaces in towns and cities, many of which didn't have much by way of alternative open public spaces.
雇佣他们。农民会在墓地里放牛，因为许多人相信在教堂墓地或埋葬地生长的草更肥沃，能产出更甜的牛奶，甚至有时会在墓地里发现妓女。所以这些是城镇和城市中开放的公共空间，其中许多地方并没有其他可供选择的开放公共空间。
But by the 1820s and 30s, a couple things happened that changed how burials worked. Firstly, there's a series of outbreaks of disease, and cities were hit with waves of typhoid and cholera and yellow fever and it was just unsanitary to keep the deceased so close to the living. Also cities were growing and downtown real estate was becoming more valuable. Gradually in the United States, the lands of the living and the lands of the dead began to separate. Grave sites ended up far away from the city.
但到了19世纪20年代和30年代，发生了一些事情改变了丧葬方式。首先，发生了一系列疾病爆发，城市受到伤寒、霍乱和黄热病的侵袭，将死者安置在离生者这么近的地方是不卫生的。此外，城市正在扩张，市中心的房地产变得越来越有价值。在美国，生者的土地和死者的土地逐渐开始分离。墓地最终被安置在远离城市的地方。
This model of a rural burial, separate from the city, took off in America in the 1830s when Mount Auburn Cemetery opened outside of Cambridge, Massachusetts. Well Mount Auburn was what was called and what is still called a rural cemetery. What that meant was that it wasn't smack dab in the center of a town. Also it was one of the first cemeteries to actually be called a cemetery, at all. Previously they'd been called, you know, barring grounds or burial grounds or church yards. Cemetery was a Greek word, meaning sleeping chamber. And just that word cemetery is so romantic and euphemistic.
这种远离城市的乡村墓葬模式在19世纪30年代随着马萨诸塞州剑桥市外奥本山公墓（Mount Auburn Cemetery）的开放而在美国流行起来。奥本山公墓被称为，现在仍被称为乡村公墓。这意味着它不在城镇的中心地带。此外，它是第一批真正被称为“公墓”（cemetery）的墓地之一。以前它们被称为埋葬地或教堂墓地。Cemetery是一个希腊词，意思是“睡眠的房间”。仅仅这个词本身就非常浪漫且委婉。
Death had once been deeply enmeshed in everyday life. Americans had home funerals in their front parlors, and encountered modest tombstones daily in their town squares. Mount Auburn made burial something removed from normal existence. Rural cemeteries were stately. They looked like they were a world apart.
死亡曾经深深地融入日常生活。美国人在前厅举行家庭葬礼，每天在城镇广场上看到朴素的墓碑。奥本山公墓使埋葬成为一种脱离正常生活的事物。乡村公墓庄严肃穆。它们看起来像是一个与世隔绝的世界。
Mount Auburn was, and still is, beautiful. With emerald grassy hills and manicured hedges, there are statues of weeping angels in Egyptian obelisks, all connected with winding walking paths. So it was a much more artful landscape, modeled on the English garden tradition of picturesque landscapes, as opposed to just simply a flat piece of ground with a bunch of stones lined up within it. This new style marked the beginning of the rural cemetery movement in America, and it would go on to influence the design of public spaces more broadly. Because this was at a time when a lot of cities didn't have public parks or botanical gardens or museums.
奥本山公墓过去和现在都很美。有翠绿的草丘和修剪整齐的树篱，有哭泣天使的雕像和埃及方尖碑，所有这些都由蜿蜒的步行道连接起来。因此，它是一个更具艺术感的景观，模仿了英国花园传统的风景如画的景观，而不是仅仅是一块平坦的土地，上面排列着一堆石头。这种新风格标志着美国乡村公墓运动的开始，并将继续更广泛地影响公共空间的设计。因为当时许多城市还没有公园、植物园或博物馆。
These cemeteries then served as the model for some of our nation's first public parks, such as Central Park in New York, which followed that picturesque garden approach that was first seen in our cemeteries. It was later picked up for college campuses, suburban subdivisions, and many other applications. The cemeteries in coma were directly inspired by the Mount Auburn model as well. They were places to go to have picnics and amble around and get away from the smog and soot of neighboring San Francisco. If the city of the living was designed for speed and efficiency in business,
这些墓地随后成为我们国家第一批公共公园的典范，例如纽约的中央公园，它遵循了我们在墓地中首次看到的风景如画的花园方法。后来它被用于大学校园、郊区住宅区和许多其他应用。科尔马的墓地也直接受到了奥本山模式的启发。它们是人们去野餐、漫步和远离邻近旧金山烟雾和煤烟的地方。如果生者的城市是为了商业的速度和效率而设计的，
the city of the dead was instead understood as a kind of quiet, peaceful Arcadia, a kind of evocation of paradise or heaven on earth where one would take one's eternal reward. Oh, and about that eternity thing. That's very American. Americans have a rather distinct practice of holding to a burial in perpetuity. You don't find burial in perpetuity in that many other places. By burial in perpetuity, he means a plot of land that is yours forever and ever until the end of time Which is different than in say Argentina or France or Italy or any number of other countries around the world Where families of the deceased typically lease a burial plot it could be for five or ten years to a hundred years and
那么死者的城市则被理解为一种安静、和平的阿卡迪亚，一种对天堂或人间乐园的唤起，人们在那里获得永恒的奖赏。哦，关于永恒这件事。这非常美国化。美国人有一种相当独特的做法，即坚持永久埋葬。你在其他地方很少见到永久埋葬。他所说的永久埋葬是指一块永远属于你的土地，直到时间的尽头。这与阿根廷、法国、意大利或世界各地的许多其他国家不同，在这些国家，死者的家属通常会租赁墓地，可能是五年、十年到一百年，
If the family doesn't maintain that lease then the remains are dug up or disinterred and what is left is often burned. The family is given the ashes and the plots are used for new burials. And this almost never happens in the United States. American cemeteries would rather double up on burials or do above ground burials than dig up remains. That's just taboo. And that's why it was so strange in the early 20th century when almost all of San Francisco's dead were dug up and evicted to make room for the living.
如果家庭不续租，遗骸就会被挖出或移走，剩下的通常会被火化。家属会得到骨灰，墓地则用于新的埋葬。这种情况在美国几乎从不发生。美国墓地宁愿进行合葬或地上埋葬，也不愿挖出遗骸。这是一种禁忌。这就是为什么在20世纪初，当旧金山几乎所有的死者都被挖出并被驱逐，为生者腾出空间时，会显得如此奇怪。
Which brings us back to the Graveyard of Colma. What happened in 1900 was that the Board of Supervisors of the County of San Francisco decided that they did not want any expansion of the cemeteries that were already in San Francisco. That's more you know Connor again of the Colma Historical Society. So the legislation was that there would be no new burials in San Francisco, and that went into effect in 1901. So no new burials. And that meant the existing cemeteries didn't have a reliable source of revenue, and so the cemeteries fell into disrepair and became these tiny wastelands for vagabonds and near-do wells and grave robbers, and also they were gross. So, in 1914, another ordinance kicked them out.
这把我们带回了科尔马的墓地。1900年发生的事情是，旧金山县监事会决定他们不希望旧金山现有的墓地进行任何扩张。这是科尔马历史协会的莫琳·康纳再次提到的。所以立法规定旧金山不再有新的埋葬，该规定于1901年生效。所以没有新的埋葬。这意味着现有的墓地没有可靠的收入来源，因此墓地陷入失修，变成了流浪汉、无赖和盗墓贼的微小荒地，而且它们很恶心。所以，在1914年，另一项法令将他们赶了出去。
They passed legislation that said, not only no new burials, but these cemeteries just looked awful, they thought they were diseased, written. So the city said the bodies have to be disinterred and moved. From 1937 into the 1940s, most of the bodies from San Francisco were dug up and moved to coma, roughly 150,000 bodies in total. To move a body with the headstone cost the family $10. And if there was no money or no next of kin, the bodies were put into mass graves in coma. But like respectful ones.
他们通过了立法，不仅规定不再有新的埋葬，而且这些墓地看起来太糟糕了，他们认为它们充满了疾病。所以城市说尸体必须被移走。从1937年到1940年代，旧金山的大部分尸体被挖出并移到了科尔马，总共约15万具尸体。移动一具带有墓碑的尸体，家属需要支付10美元。如果没有钱或没有近亲，尸体就会被放入科尔马的乱葬岗。但那是那种受人尊敬的乱葬岗。
Because when you think of mass grave, you often think of mass executions. And it was not that kind of process. It was a much gentler, respectful process. The deceased in the mass graves were blessed and memorialized and accounted for in records. And their headstones were reused as building material. Well, the mass grave headstones ended up a long ocean beach.
因为当你想到乱葬岗时，你通常会想到大规模处决。但这并不是那种过程。这是一个更温和、更受人尊敬的过程。乱葬岗中的死者得到了祝福、纪念，并在记录中进行了登记。他们的墓碑被重新用作建筑材料。嗯，乱葬岗的墓碑最终被用在了海滩上。
You'll see a lot of headstones out there. No way. Yes, they were used to keep from erosion. And if you find yourself in one of East Apark in the heart of San Francisco, look at the paved stones lining the trails and the street gutters. And you'll see that a lot of them are cemetery headstones. These headstones sometimes faded fragments of them. Sometimes completely intact are tucked
你会看到那里有很多墓碑。不会吧。是的，它们被用来防止侵蚀。如果你发现自己在旧金山市中心的东阿公园，看看铺在小径和街道排水沟上的铺路石。你会发现其中许多是墓地的墓碑。这些墓碑有时是褪色的碎片。有时完全完整，被塞进
all over the city, hiding in plain sight. And they are the closest contact most San Franciscans have with cemeteries. There are only two graveyard left in the entire city. Death is a fact of life most urban dwellers don't see and don't think about. Whereas down in coma, Maureen confronts her mortality every time she looks out her window. I look out on the cemeteries and I think, you know, these people are resting in peace and sometimes I feel overwhelmed by all the things that I have to do, but the day that I wake up that I don't have anything to do, I'm probably going to be moving into
城市的各个角落，隐藏在众目睽睽之下。它们是大多数旧金山人与墓地最亲密的接触。整个城市只剩下两个墓地了。死亡是大多数城市居民看不到也不去想的生活事实。而在科尔马，莫琳每次看向窗外时都会面对自己的死亡。我看着墓地，心想，你知道，这些人正在安息，有时我会被我必须做的所有事情压得喘不过气来，但如果有一天我醒来发现自己无事可做，我可能就要搬进
a cemetery. Most people aren't sandwiched between two cemeteries, and we don't really think about the question of what will happen to our bodies after we die. I ask the question, and very often people are like a little taken aback, either they haven't thought about it or they know I haven't made any plans. I certainly haven't made plans. And chances are you haven't either. I have no idea what will happen in my body after I die. And that's kind of unusual in the course of history. It was indeed the case that, yes, people largely knew where they were buried.
墓地了。大多数人并没有被夹在两个墓地之间，我们并没有真正考虑死后我们的身体会发生什么的问题。我问这个问题，人们通常会感到有点吃惊，要么他们没想过，要么他们知道我还没做任何计划。我当然还没做计划。很有可能你也没有。我不知道我死后我的身体会发生什么。这在历史上是相当不寻常的。确实，人们在很大程度上知道他们被埋在哪里。
Professor Keith Egnar says that prior to the Civil War Americans assumed they'd end up in their family plots or town church yards and that their parents and children would be buried there too. That is no longer the case. We move from job to job, from town to town. We frequently encourage our children to go out and explore the world. We don't really know where we're going to be ending up. Which is why today, many people have opted not to be buried at all. Cremation has become increasingly popular into our own time, and this brought with it a number of new building types, crematoria, but also the public mausoleums
基思·埃格纳教授说，在内战之前，美国人认为他们最终会葬在家族墓地或城镇教堂墓地，他们的父母和孩子也会葬在那里。现在情况不再如此了。我们从一份工作换到另一份工作，从一个城镇搬到另一个城镇。我们经常鼓励我们的孩子去探索世界。我们真的不知道我们最终会去哪里。这就是为什么今天，许多人选择根本不埋葬。火葬在我们的时代变得越来越流行，这带来了一些新的建筑类型，火葬场，还有公共陵墓，
where you have a small box containing an urn with ashes. But with cremation, you don't need a connection to one place. Ashes don't have to stay displayed in a columbarium or a mausoleum. They can be scattered anywhere you've ever lived or wanted to live. If your family and friends live all over the world, they can each have a part of you. And there are these services that you can order where ashes can be compressed into a diamond
在那里你有一个装有骨灰瓮的小盒子。但有了火葬，你就不需要与一个地方建立联系。骨灰不必一直陈列在骨灰龛或陵墓中。它们可以撒在你曾经居住过或想居住的任何地方。如果你的家人和朋友住在世界各地，他们每个人都可以拥有你的一部分。而且你可以订购一些服务，将骨灰压缩成钻石，
and worn around someone's neck or turned into a hand-blown glass paperweight. So there's a kind of break, I think, ongoing over the course of the last 100 years or more, in which people were perhaps much more rooted to the land, both in life and especially in death, by virtue of burial and knowing where they were going to be buried, then we are now. Simfrancisco's 19th century residents could never have guessed that they'd be evicted and relocated miles away from their hometown to a city of the dead.
戴在脖子上，或者做成手工吹制的玻璃镇纸。所以我认为在过去100年或更长时间里，发生了一种断裂，人们在生前，尤其是在死后，通过埋葬和知道自己将被埋在哪里，可能与土地的联系要紧密得多，而我们现在则不然。旧金山19世纪的居民永远不会想到他们会被驱逐并搬迁到离家乡几英里外的死者之城。
Their headstone strewn about the parks and beaches of the city, of the living. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Truffman with Lany Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, and me, Roman Mars. Technical production and mixed-by-sharif usif with music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our senior editor, Kurt Colstead, is the digital director director and Terran Mazza is moving to the Bay Area. Special thanks this week to Ashley Bournemann and Marcy Russell at the Chapel of the Chimes in Oakland. This episode was inspired in part by our friends at KUOW in Seattle. They have a new podcast called Terrestrial where each episode explores a personal question through the lens of climate change and the environment. Ashley Aherne, the host of the show, has a whole episode about what we should do with our bodies when we die in light of our changing landscape, and she features this architect, Katrina Spade.
他们的墓碑散落在生者城市的公园和海滩上。本周的《99%隐形》由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，兰妮·霍尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德和我，罗曼·马尔斯参与。技术制作和混音由谢里夫·乌西夫完成，音乐由肖恩·里尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，特兰·马扎即将搬到湾区。本周特别感谢奥克兰钟声礼拜堂的阿什利·伯内曼和马西·拉塞尔。本集的部分灵感来自我们在西雅图的KUOW的朋友。他们有一个名为《Terrestrial》的新播客，每一集都通过气候变化和环境的视角探讨一个个人问题。该节目的主持人阿什利·阿赫恩有一整集关于在景观不断变化的情况下，我们死后应该如何处理我们的身体，她介绍了这位建筑师卡特里娜·斯佩德。
My name is Katrina Spade, and I'm the founder and director of the Urban Death Project. Katrina's designed what she calls a recomposition center, a facility where it would be possible to compost multiple human bodies at a time. I realize this is pretty out there for a lot of people. I know the Catholic side of my family would probably freak, but listen to the way she envisions one of these centers. And remember, it doesn't exist yet. This is just how she imagines it. When you open the doors to the recomposition center, the first thing you see is this three-story, concrete form. It ends, you can see the top of it.
我叫卡特里娜·斯佩德，我是城市死亡项目的创始人和主任。卡特里娜设计了她所谓的“重组中心”，这是一个可以同时堆肥多具人类尸体的设施。我知道这对很多人来说很超前。我知道我家庭中天主教那一面可能会吓坏，但听听她设想的这些中心之一的方式。请记住，它还不存在。这只是她的想象。当你打开重组中心的大门时，你看到的第一件事就是这个三层楼高的混凝土结构。它结束了，你可以看到它的顶部。
And wrapping around that core is a series of ramps. That's sort of a meander. To hear the rest of the concept of the Recomposition Center and some other ideas about the future of death, check out the full episode when it comes out next Tuesday That's May 16th, but for right now you can just go subscribe. Again, that show is called terrestrial. Check it out. We are a project of 9.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
围绕着那个核心的是一系列坡道。那是一种蜿蜒。要收听重组中心概念的其余部分以及关于死亡未来的其他一些想法，请在下周二（5月16日）收听完整剧集。但现在你可以先去订阅。再说一次，那个节目叫《Terrestrial》。去看看吧。我们是旧金山9.7K ALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心Radio Row制作。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and have a nice subreddit too. But we release at least two articles about design and architecture that are just like the episodes, but you know, for reading on our website at 99pi.org. Radio to PO. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg。我们在Instagram、Tumblr上也有账号，还有一个不错的subreddit。但我们至少会发布两篇关于设计和建筑的文章，就像剧集一样，但你可以在我们的网站99pi.org上阅读。来自PRX的Radio to PO。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。